Hi everybody. Welcome to Google
talks. Today's a very special day.
I want to introduce a great friend of
mine and somebody that I really look up to
in the tech space.
His name is Ardell Millhouse.
What makes him unique and very special
is he has led many hackathons in Rhode
Island, has been recognized by President
Obama and Congress, men and women.
Aside from that,
the beautiful thing is that he's helped
today lead many underprivileged and
underserved markets for people that
are interested in becoming engineers.
Aside from that,
he's constantly challenging the status
quo and always making sure that many
people are involved and challenged
every day in a very technological,
digital age.
I'd love to welcome my dearest friend
and a leader in Tech and a serial
entrepreneur are not mail house
course.
Thank you, Miranda. Thanks for having me.
It's been great to be here.
All right,
so good enough to noon everyone again.
My name is RNL Millhouse and
it's an interesting story and an
incident interesting journey that we're
embarking upon and today we're going
to be talking about rebooting emerging
domestic markets.
This concept was first spoken about about
three or four decades ago by a Harvard
University professor who talked about
taking urban centers and the ticking the
underserved workers in those communities,
training them,
give them the right technical skills
or labor skills that they needed to
integrate into society here in America
wrote a really great book about it,
but the concept never really took off and
throughout my life as I grew up in the
story that I'm about to share,
I always thought about how can
we really make this happen?
How can we take it from the page in print
or on the stage as they often say in
Broadway,
right from the page to the stage,
and I'm even writing a book about it,
rebooting emerging domestic markets,
rearchitecting the middleclass
innovation process in America, and
I'm an entrepreneur,
a software developer,
but I really think of myself
as a social change agent,
someone who is trying to
bring about change and impact.
Steve Jobs talked about of all the
things that he wanted to do in his life,
he simply wanted to make
a dent in the universe.
And it wasn't about the money,
it wasn't about the
creations or the accolades,
it was about making a significant change.
And so I created a company
called Intercity geeks
along with a couple of other
gentlemen.
I'll be introducing them by name and
another organization called career devs
interested in Geeks.
Our goal is to simply fuel computer
science education and to drive innovation
driven entrepreneurship
throughout American cities
in both underserved and under
skilled markets are our main goal is
to impact 1 million plus people in our
pipeline.
The other is called career
devs and career dabs.
This launching rigorous computer science
academies along with Innovation Driven
Entrepreneurial incubators.
So while interested,
he geeks is the nonprofit arm career.
DEB's is the for profit arm.
How all this stuff comes together.
You really need to take a deep dive into
my story and it's a really interesting
story. I believe it starts off back in
Boston, Massachusetts, where I was born.
I was born to a single mother,
Dorothy Lee Millhouse and single mom,
which is really the prototypical urban
story that you hear for people of Color.
Right.
And my mother had four children.
Which one is me? Can you guys
guess? That's me right there.
Second oldest.
And what was interesting in Boston that
we went from a middle class neighborhood.
My mother ended up getting sick.
We moved from the middle
class neighborhood to a lower
income neighborhood APP.
She,
after she took ill and
yeah,
wild Roxbury, which was a neighbor
that we moved to, was very, very tough.
There was gunfire,
drug needles.
I've had guns held to my head coming from
a school where people robbing me from
money, I would get home. My
mother was like, oh, how was
your day, honey? Let me go.
Was fine. So a couple of
things were interesting. One,
we didn't know that we were
poor and we didn't know that.
I didn't know that we should be unhappy.
We were happy. We had a nice family. And,
but one day my mother, when
we were on welfare, food
stamps, section eight housing,
she took her housing certificate to the
housing authorities and said she wanted
to move and they were asking her,
where do you want to move?
And she mentioned that she wanted
to move to Cape Cod. Right.
And it wasn't until we actually
moved to Cape Cod that I notice this,
that the urban lifestyle formula,
we had been living,
that there was a vicious perpetuating
cycle that repeats itself.
So in eighth grade we packed up,
we moved to Cape Cod,
and it was, you know, people go,
this is the place that people travel
to for, for, for vacations, right?
From all around the world.
And I'm living there 365 days a year.
But I noticed another cycle,
a virtuous perpetuating cycle,
which was the opposite of what
was taking place in Boston.
And for the first time in my life,
something changed
my worldview
because
living in Boston and Cape Cod,
the dichotomy was incredibly different.
On the Cape,
I was taking courses such as Latin
or I learned one of my favorite jokes
[inaudible] suburby
where are your underwear?
We even had our, you know, a wrap
for Latin. Latin is a dead language.
It's dead as it can be. First it killed
the Romans and now it's killing me, right?
But Magnar chrome,
Cherry Tati Pula of vigor.
[inaudible] and so I'm learning
all these different things.
And when we moved to the Cape,
we didn't live in tenement buildings
that you found in the city.
We live right up the seventh hole
or the dentist pines golf course.
And I remember waking up one morning,
I saw these little white balls
in my yard and I said, mom,
why are these balls keep
coming into our yard?
And what are those people out there
doing? What are they, why do they,
are they farming? It looks like
they're trying to farm. What do they,
what are they planting? I couldn't
understand this. He says, no, honey,
they're playing golf. I
said, wow, what does golf and
I've learned about Camelot, the
Kennedys, they live 10 minutes from me.
The Kennedy compound, John F. Kennedy,
his family, everyone all right there,
their lineage.
So I heard the stories.
I was regaled with all of the tales of
their fame and their wealth and it was
just a different perspective of
learning about a former president,
but their family lives down the street.
This is the next stage
was kind of interesting.
My first job in high school took place
at a place called Fred's Turkey house.
Now this is really impactful because while
I was, I started off as a dishwasher,
then a prep cook, then a line cook,
then a shelf, but at this restaurant,
the person that owned
his name was Fred Bloom,
one of my greatest mentors
and influencers in my life.
He had about four or five restaurants on
the Cape and there was a gentleman that
went to Harvard University that graduated
in computer science who worked for him
running all of the communications.
Jeff rule.
He was talking about trying
to learn me to the dark side,
which is computer science because aren't
alley cause you don't want to be a
laborer sweating away in a kitchen
all your life. He goes, listen,
you know you love playing around with
computers and making these video games in
school. Stick with that. And so I said,
oh no. But then Fred said, hey listen,
go to Johnson Wales University.
Come back here and manage my restaurants.
So there was a light side and
the dark side tempting me.
Then in high school I took my
first computer program in class.
Pascal fell in love myself
and several of the students.
We were always getting in trouble,
doing things with code that you shouldn't
be doing and then I got a job working
for my high school making $12 an
hour as a junior. I was hooked.
I was making more than I was making in
the restaurant business and it was just
phenomenal.
Something else interesting
that that happened on the
Cape was one of my teachers
was asking where I lived in Boston.
I said, oh I remember living.
We once lived on mass ave
Massachusetts avenue and she said, Oh,
you were right down the street
from MIT. I said, am I, what
am I who? She goes, no,
Mit Ivy League university.
Never heard of it.
She goes,
it was less than a
quarter mile from me and
that really bothered me that
MIT and Harvard were so close,
but they might as well be. They might as
well have been miles away, planets away,
different universe really
going to school on the Cape. Students
would pull up in the school and BMWs,
Mercedes or just brand new cars,
brand new Toyotas.
When our car, even though we lived
on the Cape, it was still a, uh,
we were still poor. We were using a
housing certificate to live on Cape Cod,
so sometimes dropping us off to school.
We had this station wagon that had Mitch
match wheels smoke coming out of the
back of it and so I would beg my
mother like, mom, can you please just,
can you drop me off down
the street because honey,
but it's still like a quarter mile walk.
I was like,
I was just embarrassed to pull
up in the school in that car.
Okay.
What was happening was that I
was experiencing culture shock.
I was seriously undergoing a sense
of disorientation in disbelief
about what I was seeing.
My middle school,
the cafeteria was more
reminiscent of what you have here
in Boston.
We didn't have the cafeteria.
It was everything was make shift
and the food wasn't that great.
Periodically we would travel back and
forth to Boston and I began to see this
divergence between my cousins
lives in my friends' lives,
my friends and their parents on the
Cape versus they're my friends and their
parents in Boston.
As I was in Boston,
I would notice that the adults were
talking about how hard things were,
that there were no opportunities. They
just lost a job. They couldn't get ahead.
They, their electricity was being
turned off. This week on the Cape,
everything was happy and
everyone was doing fine.
And as we would go back and forth, it
was lights on, lights off, lights on,
life lights off.
And it was disconcerting.
And I didn't know, I said in Boston
and Cape Cod, 60 miles apart.
So it really, really, really
troubling back and forth. Cape Cod,
Boston,
Cape Cod to Boston.
And I remember the exact moment
that this thing happened.
I woke up one morning and I realized
that I had two worldviews because of my
friends in Boston. They all, and
myself included, when I moved,
initially moved to Cape Cod,
I wanted to be a rapper,
basketball player or some
type of athlete or entertainer
where everyone in the Kate was talking
about where we going to school,
what we're going to do without careers.
And so hearing two different worlds,
two different worldviews.
And I saw that one worldview was just
crumbling and the other was thriving.
So I left high school and I went to
college at Johnson Wales University,
computer science,
my,
like my buddy cliff and at Johnson Wales,
things really took off.
I was a computer lab assistant and
that's what I've learned about.
I learned about innovation.
I started taking some of the processes
that they had in place that took four or
five days to change the computers over
at the end of each semester and I brought
it down to a three hour process and my
bosses were freaking out. They were like,
oh my goodness,
this is amazing.
And there were a lot of other
things that I did that really,
really impacted the university.
Something really,
really bad happened though.
My freshman year,
my mother passed away all those
years of being sick on housing.
She passed away.
My younger brother and younger sister,
my older brother and myself, we had to
try to figure out what are we going to do?
My older brother said, you
stay in school, work hard,
send money home on the weekends.
And I did that until my sophomore year.
I became a senior lab assistant at Johnson
Wales, which I receive free tuition,
which really saved me because the school
was sending me notices that you have no
money, you can't, you
can't stay in school.
And I graduate Johnson Wells and
something interesting happen.
The second job that I had
was in Boston and when I was on the Cape,
my mother would tell me all the time,
pay attention or know I brought you down
here so that you could pay attention to
find out how people are becoming
successful and family after family.
What does your father do? Oh,
he's in a technology again,
there was Jeff at Fred's Turkey
house are now come to the dark side,
but every family seemed to have some
connection to some type of technical
organization working in Boston. So I
said, I'm gonna apply to a job in Boston.
I applied for this data,
telecommunications company,
walked into the company.
Another shock.
I walked in and I was the only person
of color within the entire organization
and I said, they're not going
to hire him, there's no way.
But I become really good at
what I do with technology,
computer science. So I got an offer
letter in the mail and it was for $80,000
and it was a second time.
I was a shock culture shock.
The company,
much like here at Google
cafeteria food chefs coming in,
massage therapist.
I didn't know that it
was leading up to this.
Okay.
$80,000 a year.
$15,000 annual bonus.
15,000 shares of stock. What is
stock stock? What's, what stock
is that like Campbell's stock?
I didn't know are they gonna send
me 15,000 cans of Campbell's doc?
I don't want that.
But it was culture shock round to
something else hit me.
I was no longer poor and it was
welcome to the middle class.
But I think as hard as
it was making it there,
if I had known that it was
going to be that difficult,
I probably would have given up. But
since I made it this far, I said,
well why stop at the middle class?
Why not keep on going?
What's the next second exit having store?
So something interesting
started happening. My friends,
family and neighbors started noticing,
oh Arielle, it's a new clothes,
new car,
living in a nice house.
So people were peaking and then
people started knocking on my door.
Especially my friends.
I have a friend that was in the
marines and he came up to me, says,
Arnelle listen, I just got an a marines
cause all I need to do is shoot a gun.
What do I do?
I got them involved in technology,
in and out to him.
His name is Jason,
he's African American and
another friend of mine,
Rick Jamaican background, Hov, Cambodian,
Tim, Irish American, Dave English,
Osi Latino, Tim, Kevin, Derrick,
Sam, Charlie Lin, John, Mike will,
Jeff, chuck, Devin,
[inaudible], rob, Kurt,
so many other people that
he started coming to me and
my friends to get involved
in technology,
people who were on welfare,
unemployed or severely underemployed
overall about 25 people
who now have an aggregate annual
income of over $2 million.
And if you look at the majority of those
people all got married, all own homes.
And so that cycle that my mother was
caught up in and that so many other people
were caught in single mother,
no father in the household was now
being broken in so many people's lives.
And so many children,
including myself,
my two amazing sons right here in
my amazing wife who I would not,
I would not be here without.
And
so I started thinking again,
how do we solve the
income inequality puzzle?
And the solution is simple.
We have to do it at scale.
And that's where I really began thinking
about the rebooting emerging domestic
markets.
So I had my great moment of epiphany,
seeing it,
what all of my friends had attained.
And then over the past few years,
looking at all of the pain that this
country has been going through with the
battles between race and income
and the haves and have nots.
I said,
what I've done for my friends,
I simply need to do for the
rest of the country. That's
easy, right? No problem. So
I started a company
called Intercity Geeks.
It's a nonprofit and something
interesting happened.
I put an ad up on Brown university's
website and this double major at my econ
brainiac named Rapides binkies applied.
I sit down with them,
blew me away with his intelligence.
He worked with me getting
the organization going.
And then I met another gentleman
and he's here today in the audience.
His name is cliff.
Yeah,
brainiac. You've seen like
the superman comics brainiac.
That's cliff right there and we'll
talk a little bit more about that,
but interested he geeks.
We started teaching at the middle school
level in providence and it got picked
up in the news like, wow, this is
really cool. No one's done this before,
or at least not at the scale that we
were looking to to run our programs.
We were in channel 10 we're taking
students to hackathons at Brown university
and they were growing. They were
doing amazing things of themselves.
In the red shirt here you
can see my son Matthias,
he actually teaches with me now.
He's a lead instructor for elementary
school students. He's 14 years old,
eighth grader, actually
not 14 yet. In a few weeks
he's going to be,
but he's doing amazing things and
again that generational stronghold,
that generational change effect.
Having a father figure,
a mother figure that's nurturing him
to help him grow in Elias is coming up
behind learning as well.
So we went from middle schools
to high schools teaching,
talking about how they can
get jobs in technology.
Seventy thousand seventy two thousand
dollars is the average of the PA jobs
paying and Rhode Island, the mayor
of providence contacted us and said,
hey, you're doing some great
things. What can we do together?
So we created a hackathon
for the city of Providence
and not just any hackathon,
but we were also recognized
by President Obama for our,
it was on the White House
website August 4th, 2015
the culture shock is continuing to happen.
I'm seeing the vision fulfilled
of what we're trying to do.
And for one of the hackathons that we did,
what we attempted to do,
we built a satellite communications array
to communicate with the astronauts and
the International Space Station as
it flew overhead over Providence,
the astronauts with sleeping.
But we did get a ping connection
signal with our device and,
but we've stressed to the students.
When we did this,
we partnered with a group
from Brown University,
middle school students and high school
students who assembled the communications
array,
designed it and got it working.
This is the type of innovation that we
want to let students know as possible and
they're like, now they go out there
and they have the apps on their phone.
I've had, I get calls from
students all the time, Hey,
I'm looking at the international
space station going overhead.
I'm following them on Twitter. Right,
and they're talking about engineering,
they're talking about aeronautics.
These are the types of impacts and changes
that you want to be to make everyone
can't move to Cape Cod. After that, the
governor of Rhode Island got in contact,
have contact with us through her
innovation department and we created a
hackathon for the state.
I also taught a Harvard computer science
class called CS 50 in Rhode Island.
Over 500 people applied.
We enrolled 150 and cs 50 is rooted
in the c programming language,
data structures, algorithms,
computational thinking,
strong,
strong rigor,
and it was during that course
and here's a snapshot of it.
That's my head there.
I'll give you that same view,
but during that class I met one student
that approached me halfway through.
Everyone was two or three
weeks behind in the,
except for one student who comes up to me
and says, I'm finished with the course.
I said, you can't be. That was
cliff. Toward the end of the class,
Harvard had a global computer comp coding
competition and cliff's team was only
one of 13 that finished with a perfect
score out of 630 something teams
worldwide. Perfect score. I was impressed.
We be in a hanging out a little bit and
cliff became my third geek crush that I
had in my life. The first was Jeff
rule from Fred's Turkey house.
The second was rapid lists and then cliff.
So from there we formed career Deb's
in career. DEB's is the for profit arm.
We're launching our computer science
training academy this summer.
Are we teaching people in Rhode
Island and New York in Boston?
Rigorous computer science.
We were just in Brooklyn two weeks ago.
We're coming back again in May and there
are 36 schools in the five boroughs.
Had an interested in having career
debs do work there. Same in Boston,
same in Rhode Island, so we're
expanding rapidly. In addition in our,
the way that we're going to do computer
science is different than a boot camp,
so we don't call it a computer science
bootcamp because the students are really
going to
two.
Oftentimes when we see students
graduating from boot camps,
they can't do anything significant
when they complete the course,
so we want to make sure that there's
a lot of testing in a lot of rigor in
ideation at every stage.
We want to make sure that
this is a creation portion
that they can reiterate and
from recall,
do examples that they create.
S really, really important. Plus the
focus on data structures and algorithms,
which cliff is a Jedi knight over. That'd
be a cit since we were in a dark side,
probably see it.
The other thing that's interesting is
that I've had several entrepreneurial
journeys over the years and a couple
of years ago I created a organization
called crowd signed
and I applied to one of the big
incubators and I thought, wow,
they're going to love my idea,
and they rejected me.
I didn't have an understanding of metrics,
total address,
total adjustable market space.
I didn't. There were a lot,
there were a lot of things that I didn't
understand, so I had to hit the books.
One of my friends said, oh, go up to MIT.
They're having this course
on entrepreneurship. So I
went up there, registered,
sat in on it, learned a ton. It's like,
oh bill, all that. He has his great book.
You should check it out.
Disciplined entrepreneurship.
So I internalize that
and as I've done that,
several of the people
have come to me now saying
they want some entrepreneurial help
with their products the same way.
In the same way that I helped my
friends learning about computer science,
I'm now helping people learn about
entrepreneurship. So cliff and myself,
we're going to be also teaching
about entrepreneurship and
as creatives launches, two of the
companies that we're highlighting,
one is called common connect.
It allows you to connect with people as
you would with linkedin professionally,
but socially based upon your location.
How many times are you traveling?
You're walking past someone on eighth
or ninth or 16th that you could probably
have a lot of synergy with,
but you don't know that person.
Now with common connecting your pocket
when you're passing that person you'll
know and since you're in the same
vicinity you'll be able to connect.
Another one is called cross sign
informed analytics that helped drive
the market for unsigned artists.
So it's data driven,
analytic driven,
innovative IP behind both of
these companies that we're
launching and cliffs the
lead developer on both of those.
So what's our vision?
It's the same thing that happened with
my friends, but instead of people.
Now we're also looking at corporations,
companies difference being
not just starting a business,
but what's a scalable innovation driven
I p portfolio driven incubator look like
that's designed for the
under skilled in underserved.
Because I've been
convinced by bill all let
and people from Brown
university like Dan Warsh, Shea,
anyone can learn entrepreneurship in,
anyone can learn computer science if
they apply themselves long enough,
if they hack at it long enough. And so
our goal is to create this multiplier,
this network multiplier that will really
bring upon this error where we can
reboot emerging domestic
markets here in this country.
And so over time stay tuned in.
Thank you.
Thanks.
If you are interested in getting
contact with us or following our story,
you can follow along on
city geeks.org Korea,
devs.com and you can email
cliff myself as noted.
Thanks once again.
So
we're going to take a couple of questions.
If anyone has any questions they can
feel free to ask them in or if you're
interested in working for
us and leaving Google. Yes.
And we have microphones over that.
So we're going to have each person
stand up at a microphone to ask their
questions.
Throughout all of the struggles that
you faced with to your friend, you know,
cities moving back and forth,
what kept you so motivated to continue
to go from the lower class to middle
class to now being obviously
a very wealthy individual?
Oh, I don't know if I would say very
wealthy individual, but, uh, um,
I took an Uber here this morning,
didn't have a chauffeur, but, um,
my motivation
was
interesting. So here's an
interesting story that from Cape Cod,
I remember once being out in the ocean
with some of my friends and one of my
friends said, hey, let's
swim out to my father's boat.
It was that type of situation.
So we're swimming out to what we
thought was his father's boat.
Then he told us he was joking, he
goes, this is my father's boat.
It's that went out there
as much further away.
And so in that situation there
you just keep swimming
cause you have to swim.
And as I
made it one mile or pass one goal,
I just kept going and I kept swimming and,
and then once I,
like I said, because when I made it
to the middle class, that's okay,
why did this now?
And even though it's hard work,
I'm going to keep going because I looked
back at a lot of my friends and family
that were in Boston.
Everyone's working hard,
whether you're a lower class,
middle class or upper class,
everyone has a pretty hard life in terms
of the hours that you have to put in
and different things of that nature.
So I'd rather work hard to bring about
success and also try to bring people
along with me. So it's just, you know,
I've never really thought about why.
So to answer your question,
I don't know,
but it's just something you don't give up,
you just can't give up.
And I know that I had my younger
brother and sister and that was a great
motivating factor for me as well.
And then once they were set at friends
and family that came along and you know,
you always see needs and I guess you see
needs and needs that need to be met and
you go for it. Thank
you. Any other questions?
Yes.
All right. Thanks for checking your story.
I really appreciate it. Great. Thank you.
Talk about how the goal in a inner city
geeks is to help do help inner city
youth make the jump to middleclass
through technology jobs.
Have you considered looking into other
professions like law, medicine, finance,
and other professions for people who
may not find themselves very acute to
technology?
Yes, and I believe that will be the
goal. But like with most things,
when you're starting something, you
can only do one thing well, right?
You can only do one thing.
Well. And for instance,
Google started off doing just a search
engine and now you guys are doing a
couple of things in addition to search,
right?
And so yes, but we do want to be able to
expand to bring more people into that.
Cause not everyone's going
to be a programmer or a
network engineer. Right? Yeah.
Thank you.
Hey, so thank you for taking
the town and sharing your story.
So what is success for
inner city geeks into?
What do you guys want
to accomplish over time?
So success for intercity geeks
and career Devs is pretty,
pretty large.
I always ask the question
in a seems, it seems crazy when I hear
it, when I hear the goal in my head,
it sounds crazy. But when
you think of John F. Kennedy
was standing up and saying,
[inaudible] in that New England accent,
we're going to,
by the end of this decade, we're going
to put one man on the moon. Right?
Or you look at the accomplishments of
individuals and companies such as Google
self driving cars.
Oh,
the work that's being done with tensor
flow and machine learning and just all
the advances that that's bringing out.
Bringing about my goal is to,
it's been talked about so much,
but I really believe that in America we
can set the example for having balanced
income equality.
Not everyone is going to be a Jeff
Bezos or Larry Page or a Bill Gates,
but you don't,
you don't have to have large swaths of
our society that are living in squalor.
I believe that we can,
in the impact that people have that
are underserved and under skilled,
they can contribute to the might of the
American economic engine to make us an
even stronger in greater country and
that's not just for urban markets,
but that's also for a suburban markets.
W the principal from my high school,
it says,
oh no,
we need you to come here to the Cape
because we have those pockets of under
skilled people here.
And so it's not just an urban thing is
to start a black thing or a Latino thing
or a a white thing. There are poor
people everywhere in this country,
and that's my goal. My goal is to
create balanced income equality.
Well, thanks. Once again.
I really appreciate the opportunity
being here and we'll see you next time.
[inaudible].